[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
from full house to the big house and
back on the streets
actress lori lachlan is out of prison
plus an army green beret accused of
opening fire at a bowling alley
three people dead three more wounded
authorities calling it
a random act really a motive for someone
doing such a horrific and evil act is
unknown at this time
netflix star joe exotic drops his
lawsuit against the department of
justice
why the tiger king is still hopeful for
a presidential pardon
and cardi b signals her two-year legal
battle is now over
the rapper posting on twitter she's now
free from her dispute with her former
manager
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
actress lori lachlan is out of prison
after serving two months
for her role in the college admissions
scandal
just days after christmas the full house
actress and now convicted felon
laurie lachlan is out of prison lachlan
and her husband massimo gianouli
pled guilty to paying 500 000 to get
their two daughters into the university
of southern california under the false
pretense of being on the rowing team
the largest college admissions scam ever
prosecuted by the department of justice
more than 50 people have been charged in
the scheme which is alleged to have
totaled
25 million dollars prosecutors say
parents funnel the money through a
for-profit charity scam
run by ringleader william rick singer
despite
already being able to give their
children
every legitimate advantage in the
college admissions game
instead chose to corrupt and illegally
manipulate the system
for their benefit actress felicity
huffman served just 12 days in prison
after pleading guilty to paying singer
fifteen thousand dollars
to have her daughter's s.a.t scores
secretly corrected
lachlan began her sentence on october
30th she spent just two weeks in
isolation
both after entering and before leaving
the california prison
giannoli a fashion designer is serving
five months
he's expected to be released in april
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney adam konta along with terry
austin
adam coming right to you two months
short or long sentence in your opinion
i don't think the length of the sentence
really matters right in this situation
this is sort of a unique situation
because when we look at sentences uh
the question is is it a proper
punishment and
does it make the uh does it make society
safer and could it deter a possible
crime right those are the three
questions
uh like if you look at the death penalty
the death penalty is not going to stop
anyone from committing murder
this case though lori laughlin people
don't
want to be shamed publicly people don't
want to see
their dirt gone through uh you know the
twitterverse and online
and so even though this is not an
incredibly long sentence
it's a rich person crime that i think
will legitimately deter
other rich people from taking this sort
of shortcut to get their kids into
school
with this sort of cheating advantage uh
so i think it actually will serve a
purpose
i think this is going to do a lot more
for this type of crime
than sending a drug a dramatic to jail
for buying two bags of heroin for 10
years that's not going to do any
this this could actually stop people in
her socioeconomic circle
from doing something similar all right
so deterrence i can see that
now terry often our cases involve the
death of a victim and justice is hard to
be found there
do you think that justice was found here
now that lachlan has served her sentence
i do think justice was served two months
may seem like a short amount of time but
adam hit it on the head
i think the public backlash and the loss
of income
is real punishment so i think it is
justice served
i will continue to see how this plays
out as massimo gianouli is still serving
his sentence
and to other celebrity legal news the
tiger king has dropped his lawsuit
against the department of justice
joe exotic has told a federal judge he
believes president trump has received
his pardon petition
exotic whose real name is joseph
maldonado passage
is best known for his role in the
netflix series tiger king
he's currently serving a 22-year
sentence for a murder-for-hire plot
against his rival carol baskin
and for violating the endangered species
act exotic has repeatedly and publicly
requested the president
pardon him rapper cardi b
has reportedly settled a lawsuit with
her ex-manager for 30 million dollars
the former manager sued for 10 million
dollars in 2018
claiming she didn't pay him after her
breakout hit vodak yellow
cardi b countersued for 15 million
saying her contract was unfair
the legal battle apparently is now over
cardi b posted on twitter quote
feels good to be free according to
documents attained by all hip-hop the
matter was dismissed with prejudice and
both parties agreed to handle their own
legal fees
and now to illinois angela levy brings
us the latest on a mass shooting
where the suspected shooter is a member
of the military
yeah that's right brian sadly three
people were killed another three were
wounded saturday night
at this bowling alley in rockford
illinois police went to don carter lanes
after receiving a call of shots fired
within several minutes the officers were
able to locate
what they believed was a suspect and he
was taken into custody
without any officers firing their
weapons
suspect had attempted to obscure his
identification
and hide his weapons prior to the
officers taking him into custody
now police say this man 37 year old duke
webb is the shooter
and that he had two handguns he's an
active duty member of the army
he's a green beret and he's stationed in
florida now three men
ages 73 65 and 69 were killed
a 14 year old boy was shot in the face a
16 year old girl was treated and
released from the hospital
and a 63 year old man remains in
critical condition
a gofundme page has been started for the
family of one of the victims
rockford's mayor says this has been a
tragedy for the community the shooting
happened
in the restaurant and bar area of that
bowling alley
the business district's meetings are
actually held at dawn brokers
uh you think about the
really numerous fundraisers that they
host for non-profits uh probably one
nearly every week
of the year they're hosting fundraisers
for non-profits or donating to a
non-profit
you think about all the birthday parties
that all of us who live in rockford
uh have attended at don curtis uh
they've really been a state portfolio
they're really well run
locally owned business
now sadly this shooting happened as
rockford illinois was seeing a
tremendous spike in gun violence this
year
duke webb faces three counts of murder
and three counts of attempted first
degree murder
a judge denied his request for bail and
his lawyer said to the judge today
that he may have ptsd but he has yet to
be evaluated
brian and janet so duke webb is in the
military in florida so what's the
connection with rockford illinois
yeah we spoke with the mayor about that
just briefly today he didn't go into it
a tremendous amount of detail but he
said that he believed he had a family
member in the area
and i was looking through some online
court records those indicated that he
was part of a family court case back in
1993
so we're kind of led to believe that he
has some type of connection to that area
but police are saying at this point
that the shooting appears to be random
thanks angenet we'll be sure to follow
this case through the court system
still ahead on loan crime daily body cam
video captures the moment an ohio
officer failing shoots a man
in a garage and later a texas football
player apologizes
why the high schooler is facing criminal
charges for an on the field move
those stories and more after the break
[Music]
investigators in nashville continue to
search for answers to why a man
apparently blew up himself
and his rv 63-year-old anthony quinn
warner has been identified as the only
suspect in the christmas day bombing
the tennessee bureau of investigation
says warner was not on their radar
records show his only arrest in the
state was in 1978
for marijuana possession no victims were
killed in the explosion
nashville officers are being hailed as
heroes for quickly evacuating buildings
after recording played from the rv
warning of a bombing
the fbi is now analyzing the explosive
device found at the scene
city officials in columbus ohio are
promising a prompt decision
over whether to fire a police officer
for a deadly shooting
officer adam coy was responding to a
non-emergency call
about a parked suv that had been running
on and off
on december 22nd coyne another officer
encountered andre hill
inside a garage hill a guest at the home
is seen with his back
towards the officers he then turns
around and steps towards them
with his cell phone in his left hand and
his right hand not visible
coy then shoots hill coy hit record on
his body camera nine seconds later
but a look back feature captured 60
seconds of the video
before recording the incident viewer
this question is advised
put your hands out to the side hands out
to the side now
roll to your stomach now yeah
okay hey don't get close i can't see his
hand
get your hand off from underneath you
now
you've got a medic coming
it's now up to the city whether or not
to fire officer coy
the police chief released the statement
two days after the shooting
recommending his termination
i have filed two departmental charges
alleging critical misconduct
against officer coy after an expedited
investigation
i have sustained those charges
based on these findings i am
recommending discipline
of termination some may call this a rush
to judgment
it is not we have an officer who
violated his oath to comply with the
rules and policies of the columbus
division of police
and the consequences of that violation
are so great
it requires immediate action
this violation costs an innocent man his
life
attorneys terry austin and adam conte
are with me for legal analysis terry
the franklin county coroner just
released the preliminary autopsy
confirming hill died
of multiple gunshot wounds so what's
next in this case
you know brian we're waiting to see if
there will be possible
charges of a violation of use of force
we know already he's been relieved of
duty
and there could be criminal charges but
this was yet another
death of an unarmed black man and we
keep hearing about police reform
but we're not seeing changes in ohio
alone
there have been 14 proposed bills for
changing the law and we still haven't
seen those bills
passed and we still haven't seen any
enforcement of any of these bills to
change what's happening in these police
departments yeah
adam coy was a 19-year veteran on the
police force i'm honestly a little
shocked
he was such a vet and the shooting
happened like this what do you think
yeah that's really shocking because
these are such fundamental mistakes
now to be clear what he's being accused
of right now
is is misconduct not criminal charges
misconduct
and what they're saying is that he
didn't turn on his video his body cam
uh and he didn't um and he didn't
administer
first aid soon enough or he didn't get
uh aid there soon enough
these seem like infractions that we're
talking about where this whole
uh controversy right now going back and
forth is not about criminal charges it's
whether or not he should ultimately lose
his job
even though the police office the police
chief said he recommends it
so my question is where are the
discussions about the criminal charges
he rolled up there 19 years on the force
19 years of experience
19 years of answering calls and
doing his job and he rolls up on this
particular call on this particular night
he avoids every every every instinct to
follow the protocols
and he shoots an unarmed black man
within five seconds
there's something so fundamentally wrong
about that statement
that it just boggles my mind why we're
not taking it to the next step and why
we're not talking about criminal charges
yeah he should lose his job and i think
he ultimately will but that is
that is such a minor part of what this
story should be and how it should be
told
absolutely and of course we'll be
keeping eyes to see if there are
criminal charges coming forward
because there should be here as you said
adam thank you coming up on law and
crime daily why the parents of a woman
killed in the corn ring
is now suing her husband plus on offers
christmas miracle
why it's all thanks to this bulletproof
[Music]
vest
the family of a woman stabbed to death
with a cornrake by her husband is now
suing him
todd mullis was convicted and sentenced
to life in prison for murdering his wife
amy
now amy's mother and stepfather have
filed a wrongful death lawsuit against
mullis
asking to be quote reasonably
compensated the suit claims mullis
breached his duty of care by stabbing
her
it's also asking for compensation on
behalf of her estate and their two
children
mullis took the stand in his own defense
during his trial on cross-examination
the prosecutor played his 9-1-1 call
claiming mullis was cursing his wife
while performing chest compressions
on her
todd do you whisper cheating whore right
there no
so you don't remember what you whispered
no
okay i'm gonna play another clip for you
do you know what you whispered there
did you hear that so i'm gonna play that
part one more time
right there do you say go to hell
cheating whore no
so you don't hear that no you didn't
hear at 6 53
cheating whore you didn't hear that
i didn't hear that word right at that
after you hear a ping
you don't hear go to hell cheating whore
no
terry there's no love lost between
mollusc and i and to his family hey get
that money
but i've never heard of a husband's
legal duty to care for his in-laws on
behalf of the wife or their daughter or
child
does this make sense to you you know it
may seem
odd but in this you know case they do
have a right to sue
in iowa the parents of a deceased child
including an adult child has the right
to sue if they can show that they've had
some sort of financial loss so yes they
have the right to bring this claim
nice now adam i think you can come up
with an argument or two that would be
beneficial to the family
or do you think this is a losing battle
altogether for them where do you fall
i i fall on and befuddlement what is the
point of this
uh he's in jail for the rest of his life
his money would naturally flow to his
children
all this is going to do is be an
unnecessary lawsuit
which will tie up legal funds that will
stop them from getting more of his
inheritance
and and his wealth whatever that may be
you're trying to bleed a stone and
whatever is there for the kids you're
going to diminish
i don't understand the point of this
lawsuit at all you've got your justice
he's in jail
well i i just don't understand the point
of this yeah and now you put it that way
that
all of his funds would naturally feed to
the children maybe they're trying to
expedite the process but again
they're going to depreciate some of that
property or some of that wealth that he
has i agree
but we'll keep eyes on that thanks adam
and terry when we come back
the apology from a high school football
player the move that got him bench from
the team
and booked him into jail next
welcome back officials in new york are
calling this next story a christmas
miracle
terry austin has the details brian a new
york police officer has an extra reason
to be grateful
this holiday season the nypd says this
bulletproof vest
saved an officer's life on christmas eve
a mother called 911 repeatedly
saying her daughter's boyfriend was
threatening to shoot them
officers then arrived at the brooklyn
home to interview the family
body cam video apparently captures what
unfolded next
the perpetrator arrives preliminary
looking at the body cameras myself terry
monahan
see incredible bravery by the officers
you see the
girlfriend point out and next thing you
hear shots being fired
our officer is struck once in the back
where it penetrates the vest
approximately right here
and does not penetrate the skin
thanks terry a texas high school
football player criminally charged after
tackling a referee
is now apologizing cameras were rolling
earlier this month when senior defensive
lineman
emmanuel duran rushed the field the
referee had ejected duran
from the game after two penalties one
for unsportsmanlike conduct
tyron is then seen running across the
field and slamming into the ref
we have two fouls both on the edmond kai
bobcats late hit on the quarterback
and we'll be back
ron is now charged with assault his
attorney posted a video on youtube
of the player apologizing to those that
he affected
to mr frey gracia i would like to
apologize to you personally
i hope you're doing well i am extremely
sorry for my actions
towards you and i hope one day you can
accept my apology
to my teammates like for you all to
please accept my apology
for putting you all into this bad
situation and letting you off the
playoffs
i hope you can please accept my apology
to my mom and dad i am extremely sorry
for putting them into this tough
situation
adam call me jaded say hey hate the
player not the game
but this apology seems less like an
apology and more like a lawyer saying
hey you've gotta weak case you're on
video assaulting this guy
maybe we should get ahead of this and
apologize what do you think
i think that could be part of it uh but
quite honestly i think
you know the kid's got no record he's
probably going to end up with an anger
management class
community service and maybe a slap on
the wrist
i think this is more about this kid's a
star wrestler he's a star football
player
and he i bet he was one ready to go to
college and play sports
i think this is more about trying to
save his image to so to convince some
college
to give him a chance so he can continue
his professional career that's my guess
yeah maybe down the line he kind of
floats and says boys will be boys
i don't know but terry genuine apology
legal tactic or something else
you know brian i think it is a genuine
apology and i do think it's a sound
legal tactic i mean first of all if you
look at him and you read the body
language
he looks like he is scared to death and
i think that means he's being genuine
secondly if you look at his parents they
are
dead serious they look as though they're
saying look you've screwed this up you
better
fix this and you better prove that you
are going to rehabilitate yourself
and so frankly i hope that the apology
helps to mitigate the punishment i mean
he's been charged with the class a
assault he was jailed there's a ten
thousand dollar bond
so i think that this apology hopefully
will help
down the road yeah i mean my only two
cents is i was a college athlete i
played d1 and d2 soccer
and i can understand what this young man
is probably potentially
losing with this so i think apology and
some good legal tactics is definitely a
good way to uh
help move forward as you were saying
adam this might be something that he's
trying to
push forward for his next step in life
with college and i wish him all the best
adam terry thank you as always for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you